from across the Black Seas of infinity
and beyond the mists of time
yog-sothoth watches always waiting for
he is the guardian between worlds and he
alone holds the key to unlock the gate
for when the ancient rites have been
spoken and the lords of Darkness have
awoken only then shall the gate between
the stars once more be open
yog-sothoth is an enormous cosmic entity
with power that we as humans cannot
comprehend power that may even rival the
great creator of all as a thought in
terms of overall size yog-sothoth has
undoubtedly one of the biggest entities
an entirety of the mythos dwarf Innova
Cthulhu in the same way that he would
dwarf over humanity he is an all-knowing
all-seeing an all-powerful being that
can be found just outside of the
universe he watches all from the outside
and nothing can be hidden from him he is
the embodiment of time and space and
spans across an infinite number of
universes he and the multiverse are one
your cthis said to be immortal and
invulnerable and being able to see all
means he possesses a level of
intelligence that we cannot imagine he
does however share this forbidden
knowledge with those that summon him but
before the deity can be summoned a human
life must be sacrificed and unspeakable
acts must be committed for such
knowledge always comes with a price born
from the name of Smith's the much like
the other outer God's his true form is
inconceivable to humanity and so he's
often described in a variety of
different ways depending on the story
the most common manifestation of yokes
are Thoth is as an enormous mass of
growing orbs that are continuously
merging these orbs eventually grow so
big that they break apart from each
other
and then repeat the process of growing
emergent in a continuous loop there are
also some descriptions of numerous eyes
and flailing tendrils this particular
depiction I personally think is quite
fitting as time-space and a universe is
in constant flux always moving and
always changing so having this
represented in York seselis appearance
really does highlight this aspect of his
character now as you can imagine it's
pretty difficult to picture a deity that
has been described to you as being
everywhere in everything which is why
York's with off much like Nyarlathotep
has several avatars which provide
numerous aliases and nicknames ranging
from the lurker at the threshold and the
beyond one to the key in the gate and
the opener of the way the name York's
Arthas first mentioned in La Crosse
the case of Charles text award which was
written in 1927 and then published in
1941 we don't actually get to meet
York's is off here but his name is
mentioned as part of an incantation
Lovecraft will then go on to mention
York's us often several other stories
with the most noticeable being the
Dunwich horror in this story Joxer Thoth
is a father of Wilbur Whateley a hideous
looking young boy who Metchosin ages
abnormally quick because of his strange
appearance Wilbur his family had been
shown from society but his grandfather
than in doctorates him into the study of
witchcraft and dark rituals were burned
his grandfather soon become aware of
invisible entity that lives on their
farm
this entity continuously grows until it
reaches the size of the entire farmhouse
Wilbur's grandfather does died and his
mother disappears leaving him as the
only person left to look after this
entity but Wilbur himself has his own
plan as he wishes to summon the great
old ones but his family's copy of the
Necronomicon is missing the required
pages he then breaks into the local
university to find these missing pages
but he's unfortunately killed by a guard
dog he's called strangely enough just
melts leaving no evidence of his death
with no one left to look after this
invisible entity the Whateley farmhouse
explodes and the monster run pages for
Dunwich killing numerous families and
policemen with help from professors from
the local university a spell is cast and
with the use of magic powder the
entities finally revealed the monster
that makes it known that its twin
brother was Wilbur but werewolves are
resembled a human his brother much
closer resembled their father the orcs
are thought the spell that was cast
would eventually destroy this entity
leaving the small town of Dunwich to
recover from the terrors that they had
just witnessed the Dunwich horror is one
of my favorite pieces of Lovecraft's
work and it's a story that I may
actually do a reading on for you guys in
a future video
I may even discuss the life of warble
widely in some greater detail
yog-sothoth became a deity used in many
of Lovecraft stories and the works of
many other influential writers with
August Derleth being one of the most
noticeable Lovecraft himself never
really used the term that Cthulhu Mythos
and many saw photos works as the Aqsa
Thoth mythos or York saw three for
anyone looking to get into the works of
Lovecraft and the Cthulhu Mythos or just
learn about yokes Asaf in general the
Dunwich horror is definitely a great
introduction and one that I would
recommend if you have any stories
featuring new yorks of thought that you
feel like a worth of mention or you just
like to discuss a date in general then
let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
in fiction explained
[Music]